in the 2030s thanks to the rapidly
increasing oil prices qatar's economy
was booming out of control
this led to the country heavily
investing and trying to combat nature's
plan and turn the desert into fertile
land
and for a while there it was working
but then the oil ran out
by the 2040s the sand was winning the
fight and slowly the city was being
taken back by the desert
it was only those who could afford to
leave that did while the rest remained
under the led skyline that doha was once
famous for
then following the overwhelming
sandstorms was famine and government
protest
and within no time at all the military
police were everywhere
they were trying their best to stop
qatar from being the next country to
follow in the non-patrioted trend that
was occurring across the planet
in the year 2040 a journalist called
kavan bitcher was surfing through the
dark net in pursuit of information
around the nopats the soldiers who
didn't have a place they could call home
who also happened to be enemy number one
in the eyes of government officials
suddenly during the early hours of the
morning kavan was contacted by an
anonymous source claiming to be the most
wanted man alive
oz
oz was the commander of the largest
known group of nopat forces
however kavan had received messages like
this before and time and time again it
ended up being absolutely nothing
or in some situations it was government
agents working on the anti-nopak
campaigns
he even once had a guy accuse him of
being oz
but what happened next proved that there
was something different about this
particular source
moments after the chat ended qatari
police broke down the door accusing
kavan of aiding a terrorist
fortunately for him an approaching
sandstorm provided a window of
opportunity for him to escape a rest
and whilst using the cover of the storm
to hide from the armored vehicles that
were looking for him kavan began to
notice some strange messages coming
through on the massive overhead led
signage
through these adverts he was able to see
the notepad emblem flashing through
along with a number of other mysterious
symbols and images
piecing these together kavan followed
what he thought could be a way to find
the no pets and even if it wasn't he
couldn't exactly hang around where he
was for very long half of the city was
looking for him
following the clues he ended up at the
underground construction far beneath the
abandoned football stadium
outside a man in his 50s dressed in
casual knee-length shorts points his
flashlight towards the tunnel entrance
his relaxed appearance and body language
confused kevin what was going on
the man then thrust out his hand towards
him and said toyota guskovsky
and then in perfect arabic said this was
a one-time thing
as kevin makes his way down through the
dark tunnels he wonders if he'll ever be
able to call doha home again
but as he found out a year later
qatar would become a failed state
and the city of doha
lost to sand
almost two months after leaving doha the
trail of clues kavan was following led
him to alain india
there he found a safe house made up of
shipping containers
and inside were a number of heavily
armed no pet soldiers
after speaking with them kevin
discovered that this group included a
former intelligence officer doctor
nightclub bouncer and car mechanic
one of the men a man named nevin rau
seemed more approachable than the rest
he was a notorious indian hacker and
ex-special forces officer of the indian
navy
rao explained that during the 30s armed
task force units started to pop up
around the globe to help assist in
moving cargo around the world and
between the non-patrioted
all because countries were unwilling to
help feed the stranded families
so the no pets took it upon themselves
unfortunately these operations were
about to become even more dangerous
and when the world's governments started
to crack down on the no pets they began
treating these units like smugglers and
pirates
this particular task force that kevin
had stumbled across was missing
something that was reasonably integral
to the operation
a boat
it was all starting to make sense to him
now
this is why this group of individuals
iron o lang one of the largest
shipbreaking yards in the world
they were going to commandeer one
unsurprisingly after the second great
depression in the late 30s there was
very little to be shipped around the
world
so the shipping transportation industry
decided to recoup some of its costs by
turning to shipbreaking facilities and
convert their unused fleets back into
high tensile steel
however elaine soon became famous for
something else
as the ships destined for scrap metal
started magically disappearing
and then only to be discovered months
later amongst the ever-growing no-pap
fleet
and it was soon discovered that corrupt
businessmen were using the black market
to sell these ships to the nopats
once the indian military found out about
this they immediately began setting up
patrols and guards in every attempt to
shut it down
intrigued kevin decides to join the
notepads on their mission
navigating the airline coast is an
incredibly treacherous business at the
best of times
and in the gale force winds that night
and whilst pursued by the indian army
the gunfire sounded like it was coming
from every direction
during their mission at one point rao
was struck by a bullet
yet occasionally brushed it off and took
the helm
piloting them around the black iron
corpses of ships that blocked their
escape route
with 25-foot swells he navigated the
ship with ease leaving their pursuers
far behind their wake and stuck
surrounded by the graveyard of tankers
by 1 32 am the magic act was complete
and they had vanished far across the
21st parallel
and the beat up old container ship now
unofficially named the copperfield began
her journey as a notepad
it's been almost three months since
kavan and the task force of nopats had
fled the atlante coast on board the
copperfield container ship
and during this time they've been
transporting everything from food
supplies to computers and tech equipment
their very latest pickup 65 australian
refugees
next stop singapore's brawny island
it had begun around the mid-30s when the
rising sea levels had swept away a third
of the commercial ports around the world
in an attempt to resist this new threat
to their economy
singapore built a sea wall in an effort
to shield their seaport from the massive
storms that followed on from the rising
seas
brani island was established and fully
ai automated in the way of cargo
distribution and is one of the central
hubs to the global trade system
even though rao had provided his crew
with very convincing fake ids to help
them get through the scanners
everyone was on edge and completely
silent as they approached their
destination
the singaporean port authority was
renowned for their aggressive responses
to any unwanted visitors
so if they did happen to sense anything
out of place the repercussions could be
very unfortunate for those concerned
a specialist by the name of casper
vandala explained to kevin that
singapore used to tolerate the no pets
however things started quickly going
downhill as more and more people passing
through started throwing out the no pat
sympathy card regardless of whether or
not their intentions were true
the us who placed an incredible amount
of value and significance on this
particular trade port were also becoming
increasingly wary of losing this
location so they began pushing all of
their anti-nopat propaganda which in
turn eventually forced singapore to
completely shut the notepad fleets out
they managed to dock undetected and by
using his ovp recon drone casper sweeps
the area and is able to give the all
clear
rao began quickly directing the refugees
into an old shipping container
inside was a toilet bedding and enough
supplies to last 10 days
unfortunately before they were able to
get everyone safely inside they were
spotted
almost immediately a number of alarms
and sirens began to echo throughout the
port
and robotic security forces called
rangers
suddenly appeared and began advancing
towards them
casper wasting no time rapidly took them
down using his rifle
escaping back onto their vessel the
copperfield slowly departed from the
dock while rao hacked into the automated
distribution system and proceeded to
drop containers wherever he could in an
attempt to block the pursuing vessels
the singaporean port authority followed
them out into the open waters
with the sound of gunfire and battle
cries coming from behind them their foes
seemed to be catching up on them
suddenly there was a dead silence
but then this ended abruptly and an
enormous booming sound from a cannon
being fired was heard
kavan and the others braced for impact
yet almost immediately he realized that
the sound didn't come from behind them
out in front of the copper field on the
horizon they see a huge number of
fishing trawlers container ships tug
boats and much much more
it's a no-pat fleet
the singaporean port authority is now
vastly outnumbered and immediately they
call off the chase and head back towards
the coast
the copper field has been floating
around somewhere in the yellow sea for
the last two days waiting on orders from
higher up
specialist webster mckay tells kavan
that oz generally only provides just
enough intel to keep the operations
moving
he sends this out via telegraph with
only basic points so only those intended
to receive these messages would be able
to understand them
kavan has been passing the time by
keeping up to date following the steady
stream of news being broadcasted around
the globe
as it turns out there was one story in
particular that would soon involve the
copperfield and its crew
[Music]
the news report talks of an incident at
daesong electronics
south korea is one of the few success
stories of the last decade
their economy wasn't just surviving it
was growing
and one of the companies that can be
credited with the bulk of the success is
daeshong electronics
before the blackout in 2040 they dropped
earth back into the dark ages
most of the world had switched over to
satellite internet
this earthbound internet service
provider came up with a solution that
would get the world back online without
the need to roll out expensive hardware
across the planet
this isp was called k-net
by 2041 daesong had 60 of all internet
traffic running through its servers
which in turn flowed through to the
quantum data center in the middle of
song do
naturally the sheer volume of
information going through this data
center would provide a significant
tactical advantage for those who were
able to get their hands on it
so us and russian intelligence networks
keep a very close eye on what's
happening here
at around 7 30 a.m an executive
assistant at daesong electronics made
out with 10 terabytes of internal data
from the headquarters in seongdu south
korea and escaped on a stolen corporate
helicopter
the identity behind this was an
unexpected korean woman in her twenties
immediately it was assumed that she was
a foreign intelligence asset from one of
the two main superpower countries the us
or russia
but what they didn't realize is that
there was a third faction who was
interested in this intel war
after kavan finished with the news he
headed up above deck
while looking over the horizon he
noticed something approaching in the
distance
it was a black helicopter and on the
side was the daesong logo
the entire crew has now assembled on the
side of the ship
suddenly the helicopter appears to lose
control and eventually crashes down in
the distance
caven looks around at the crew but no
one seems to be particularly concerned
about this
and a minute later it would all make
sense
above the ship there was a woman
parachuting down
it was the korean woman who had made off
with the intel from daesong electronics
[Music]
after she landed on the deck casper and
rao quickly escort her inside
she is known as specialist jaisu paik a
non-pet agent put in place by oz who's
been working undercover at daesong
kavan reflects back on his time over the
months with his crew of no pets
the government had led everyone to
believe that they were the enemy
but after singapore he was convinced
that they were the sympathetic underdogs
making the hard choices to help the
struggling survive
but now
he was witnessing them infiltrate
international tech giants beating the
global superpowers at their own game
perhaps there is far more to this group
of nationless soldiers that we've been
led to believe
since leaving korean waters the nopats
have been conducting a number of trade
missions for oz
once again on the command bridge the
telegraph machine begins to receive a
message
we will receive five containers get them
to kuru
just over 24 hours later the notepad
crew are yet again conducting another
trade
but this time with a russian cargo ship
five containers are craned onto the
copper field
their destination french guiana
the manifest states that the containers
are filled with sensaco gmo pineapples
which have a stable shelf life of up to
24 months
kevin thought this was pretty sus
why would the russians need no pets to
move fruit
yet when the containers landed on deck
they made a very distinctive clanging
sound
french guiana was easily one of the most
dangerous places on earth but regardless
three weeks later they were there
unloading and moving the cargo by rail
[Music]
the blackout of 2040 tipped the world
upside down and while everyone speaks
about the internet dropping off
it was the military implications that
really stirred things up
by having no spy satellites or feasible
ways to keep an eye on each other the
superpowers were growing paranoid and
placing huge importance on getting
hardware back up in the sky
the americans had lost the cape
canaveral space force station in florida
due to the rising sea levels
and rumors were starting to float around
about them turning to the old eu launch
site in koru
they would use this site to launch their
equipment into space
however russia had obviously caught wind
of these rumors too and had been
encouraging uprisings against the
american presence in french guiana
specialist maria felk a former combat
medic
said sparking unrest is sort of russia's
specialty
and to be fair it doesn't take much to
get this place riled up
kevin could see by the look on her face
and the concern in her voice that she
was obviously a bit worried about what
was to
come a week later kavan and the no pets
arrived in koru
there they were to hand off the cargo to
the local militia
on arrival kevin noticed that all of
them were heavily armed with russian
weapons
one by one the containers were opened
and checked
cavend began to laugh as on opening the
first cargo doors revealed that they
were in fact pineapples
however after clearing these aside the
true intention of this delivery was made
known
the container was packed to the brim
with volkov multi-munition launchers
russian rocket launchers
but before anyone could say a word the
sound of gunfire began to echo around
them
and american troops started flooding
into the area
while trying to duck for cover kevin was
struck by a bullet causing him to
immediately pass out
by the time he worked he was on the back
of a flatbed truck and escaping the
battlefield
his wounds were being tended to by maria
who was frantically wrapping bandages
around the gunshot wound to his abdomen
while fleeing the war zone kavan ended
up on board a ship that was heading
toward russia's oil station on
antarctica
with the rapidly rising sea levels by
2039 countries were finally starting to
understand the importance of leaving
antarctica and its ice alone
everyone except the russians
who in secret were violating the
international treaty that was protecting
the ice continent from drilling
eventually over time the remote science
facility located at queen maudland
quietly became a refining operation
responsible for up to 4 000 barrels of
crude oil
daily
it was here that no pets from across the
globe would visit this area to refuel
however recently things were beginning
to change
as the fight for control and dominance
between russia and america continued to
grow
the superpowers were looking for ways in
which to bolster their influence
and now the oil was being cut off to the
no pets
the only way now to get it from this
facility is to swear allegiance to
russia
this was a price that oz is unwilling to
pay
now stranded on the continent with
nothing much to do
kevin stumbles across another nopat
specialist
this one by the name of constantine
angel
whose own vessel has been stuck here for
three weeks
angel states that this is practically a
hostage situation and that ultimately
war is coming
it's only a matter of time until america
comes for this place
as more time passes
more and more no pet vessels are winding
up stranded here debating the offer of
fuel for fealty
the cold in isolation is crippling and
many take the bargain
witness to this angel comments on how
short-sighted this is
that no pets shouldn't be choosing sides
he says to think of poland in world war
one their country hadn't been on the map
for 150 years
the polish legion did whatever for
whomever to make sure that when the dust
settled they still had a country
sometimes war is the only way home
caven begins to recognize this rallying
called arms
it's something that oz has been saying
for a long time
and it ultimately works to keep his
notepads intact and on mission
suddenly loud foghorns sound
and on the horizon a large american
destroyer can be seen making its way
towards the facility
this is quickly followed by the sound of
two large cannons being fired from the
shore
the american ship returns a warning shot
and over a loudspeaker a confident voice
orders the russians to stand down
the flag the ship is flying is the no
pet emblem
later kavan would find out that oz had
sent his most trusted captain to rescue
the stranded notepads before they
succumbed to the russian demands
kevin made his way aboard the ship along
with the other refugees
in his head eckhardt would angel had
said and all he could hear was those
words being repeated over and over again
there was a fight coming and it was
something he wanted no part in
yet there he was
stranded aboard a warship
maybe oz is right
and war
is the only way home
the mfs-04 exodus is an ali burke class
destroyer under the command of a former
us marine
[Music]
is in his barracks packing up his things
as the warship heads towards freetown
port
once there he plans on flying to cairo
and take up a position with sinsako
agrotex corporate communications
since kill were responsible for using a
private army to put a stop to riots
outside their walls last year
they're also the ones who provided
containers of pineapples that made a
clang sound
kavan has had enough
after 13 months of traveling around the
globe fearing for his life 24 hours a
day
he is ready to leave the notepads behind
he started this journey wanting to learn
more about them but not to die as one
and that this may be the last
opportunity he gets to leave
kevin's home is gone
taken by the sands
but egypt is one of the few countries to
come out on top during this time
in 2038 as traditional bread production
was failing sinceco agritech came up
with a two-part system to replace it
the first part included genetically
modified crops that were able to thrive
in dry and barren environments
the second part was a revolutionary
desert irrigation project
the reason since code decided that egypt
was the best place for this farm
was because of the nation's view on no
paths
egypt is the one place on earth where a
notepack can lose the label and join a
country
provided they are willing to work behind
the wall
they have a home
this was kavan's plan
to take up work and leave the notepads
as they sail towards the african coast
he continues to think about the
conversation he had with angel
that the superpowers were already on
course for a war
if the 1.2 billion no pets were to get
involved it would only lead to more
strain on a world that has already had
enough
to make things worse the no pets are
clearly a fractured group with varying
agendas
a war within a war is looking to be the
most likely outcome
which would only prolong the inevitable
even further
by 6 30 pm the crew are finally able to
see freetown port on the horizon
currently only specialist rao is aware
of kavan's plans to disembark
but soon
this wouldn't matter
the warship suddenly starts veering away
from the direction they were headed
taking a left turn they're now heading
north
[Music]
kavan can't believe his eyes
they were so close to the port
why have they suddenly changed course
where are they headed
he rushes to the bridge to find answers
when he gets there he sees a familiar
sight
an old telegraph machine much like the
one on the copper field
oz had sent new orders
before the captain slams the bridge door
closed caven captioning not available
[Music]
the firestorms began in central
[Music]
satellites have caused a global blackout
of communications and navigation systems
both russia and the us claim the other
is responsible for the employers of the
act
russia are both being accused of
building armed
the exodus has been rerouted to england
now a failed state london is under three
feet of water
it's still a mystery as to why oz has
directed the nopats to this area
regardless captain kimball irish graves
went to shore to rendezvous with the
contact
awesome at the drop
good
the informant has arrived
[Music]
that briefcase is
usually i know what i'm risking my neck
for
usually i don't explain myself
[ __ ]
there you are
[Music]
ah
bukowski
[Music]
irish returned to the ship with an
injured soldier a briefcase and
instructions to meet oz's men somewhere
in the seas south of europe
the plan was simple
hand over the extracted intel and await
the next set of orders from oz
but after discovering the true
intentions behind it irish had a change
of heart
irish you trade
how much of the no pets pay you to [ __ ]
over your home country
my loyalty is with the refugees on this
boat
that includes you now
irishman
listen
if you give us that case
that [ __ ] terrorist will start world
war three
that's what they always say pack
believe that [ __ ] if you want to
but i know what i'm fighting for
irish had originally joined oz because
he agreed with the need for no pets to
unify if they were ever going to have a
place in this new world
the main difference being that oz thinks
this can only happen if the old world
dies
he wants a war
he wants america and russia to burn each
other to the ground
as a marine irish saw firsthand what
happened to civilians during times of
war
he knows that by pushing a war like this
that the no pets would end up being
taken down alongside with them
irish are both fighting for the same
thing
no pet survival
but are doing so through very different
means
one was trying to stay out of america in
russia's reach
and the other was actively trying to
manipulate them
this is what the intel in that briefcase
was all about
coordinates to an american secret the
russians wanted
bait to draw the superpowers into an
all-out war
i don't think we have a choice
head straight into that store that's a
category five sir
ah
that's home field advantage
oz's men are now hovering above the ship
sensing that the deal was off they
opened fire
irish orders his men to steer the ship
directly towards the incoming storm to
use it as cover
as men started flooding onto the deck of
the ship a battle ensued between the two
factions
yes
oh
oh
cavend hid downstairs with the other
refugees
but eventually the fight came to them
the watertight door that was shielding
them
suddenly exploded off his hinges
a blood-soaked soldier came barrelling
in and found what he was looking for
leverage
irish's seven-year-old son omar
witnessing this
kevin knew something had changed in him
over the last 13 months through
everything he had seen he wasn't
thinking like a journalist anymore
he was thinking like a notepad
and now there was a no packed child that
needed his help
kevin is no soldier but he ran after the
man anyway
suddenly he hurt the american soldier
that irish had shot in london clayton
pakowski
he was still handcuffed to the bed
promising to help kavan didn't see that
he had much of a choice but to trust
this man
plus he had the kind of look in his face
that he'd seen in a number of other
specialists that he'd met along this
journey
pakowski managed to save irish's son
but it cost him his life
on top of this
oz's men managed to successfully extract
the intel from the briefcase
after a year of traveling with the no
pets
kavan found the answer he was looking
for
the notepads are everything people say
they are
smugglers
sinners
saints
and so much more
the world created the non-patrioted
and then blamed them for its problems
but now this task force might be the
very key to saving it
[Music]
when the smoke cleared
kavan and the crew could all see the
look in the captain's eyes
oz had to be stopped from setting fire
to the world
irish had gone from marine to nopat
but he was still just a soldier taking
orders
now
it was his time
to lead
only one way to stop this war
that's to get in the middle of it
put a call out to any notepad who will
listen
36 hours to noah
get ready
to fight
[Music]
incoming five
attention all squads